hasta ahora sólo hemos justificado que
la curva de demanda de dinero esté
inclinada hacia abajo o tenga pendiente
negativa pero probablemente pienses que
si este es un mercado no hemos pensado
en un punto de equilibrio para hacer eso
necesitamos pensar en la oferta de
dinero en vídeos anteriores empezamos a
pensar en la oferta de dinero y
pensaremos en ello en vídeos futuros
hablando sobre diferentes políticas
monetarias pero en un modelo clásico
suponemos una oferta de dinero
perfectamente inelástica así que la
dibujamos como una línea vertical que es
otra manera de decir que la oferta de
dinero no se ve afectada por las tasas
de interés nominal esta es la oferta de
dinero o m
lo llamaré o m1 donde intersecta con la
cantidad de dinero justo aquí lo llamaré
m sub 1 y este punto donde se intersecta
es el punto de equilibrio en nuestro
mercado de dinero la tasa de interés de
equilibrio justo aquí la podemos llamar
r 1 este será el costo de oportunidad
por conocer
el dinero en efectivo ahora tengo que
explicar esto un poco este es un modelo
clásico hablaremos de esto en futuros
vídeos en la mayoría de las clases de
introducción a la economía se habla
sobre este modelo clásico donde el banco
central establece la oferta de dinero y
no cambia la tasa de interés nominal y
después la tasa de interés nominal se
determina esencialmente por este punto
de equilibrio ahora en el mundo en el
que vivimos en realidad sucede al revés
los bancos centrales en realidad apuntan
a una tasa de interés nominal y si el
banco central es capaz de alcanzar esa
tasa de interés objetivo eso va a
determinar la cantidad real de dinero
así que mantener esa explicación en tu
mente pero en una clase de introducción
de la economía suponemos este mundo
ahora que tenemos este pequeño modelo
para nuestro mercado de dinero pensemos
qué pasa en distintas situaciones
pensemos en una situación en la que por
la razón que sea la gente pierde la
confianza en la red eléctrica qué
pasaría con la curva de demanda de
dinero llamemos a esta curva bm sub 1
pausa el vídeo y piensa lo bueno si la
gente pierde la confianza en la red
eléctrica entonces este motivo
precaución para tener dinero se vuelve
más fuerte independientemente de cual
sea el costo de oportunidad de mantener
el dinero la gente va a querer tener el
dinero porque podrían decir oye no sé si
podré tener acceso al dinero si la luz
se va otra vez no podré ir al cajero
automático o los bancos van a cerrar por
lo que a cualquier tasa de interés
nominal la gente va a querer conservar
más dinero y eso recorrerá la curva de
demanda hacia la derecha
esta será de m sub 2 la tenemos
recorrida a la derecha y si pasa esto si
la demanda de dinero se incrementa qué
pasa con la tasa de interés nominal de
equilibrio si vemos este punto que
tenemos aquí suponemos que la cantidad
de dinero no ha cambiado tenemos una
tasa de interés de equilibrio tasa de
interés nominal se ha ido para arriba y
esto tiene sentido si hay más gente que
quiere conservar su dinero para hacer
que esa gente se deshaga de ese dinero
tienes que ofrecerles más el costo de
oportunidad de tener ese dinero tiene
que subir y puedes imaginar el escenario
contrario si por alguna razón la gente
no piensa que la luz se vaya a ir o
piensan que no necesitan mucho dinero en
efectivo para hacer transacciones o
realmente no están especulando bueno la
curva de demanda de dinero se moverá a
la izquierda y en esa situación tendrás
una disminución en la tasa de interés
nominal de equilibrio aquí voy a dejar
esto considera estos modelos con cierta
reserva son
verificaciones del mundo real
especialmente aquí donde suponemos una
oferta de dinero perfectamente
inelástica lo que no es el caso en el
mundo real pero podemos usarlos con el
propósito de iniciar el estudio del
mercado de dinero hasta el próximo vídeo